Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Cutters. Welcome to another Read Your Genes podcast where we go over all your questions that you might have
genetically and we have several that came in today. So let's jump right in and go over these first question
question we actually get a lot could my cancer be caused by genetic defects people often think and really when they started to map out the
human genome when they started the human genome project a couple decades ago, they thought that they were going to find
you know genes that caused everything and they thought that you know genetics were going to be the answer the key that
open the door to all disease, including cancer that there is going to be a lymphoma gene and there is going to be a breast cancer gene and there was going to be a
little bit of this and that. Well, your genes can affect cancer, even the bronca genes that you hear so much about with breast cancer and a
very cancer and hormone positive cancers, the bronca genes, the bronca genes don't cause cancer, your bronca genes are tumor suppressor genes, meaning that
there you have certain genes in your in your cells, all your cells have these certain genes that will suppress cancer if the cell goes into rapid
replication. So if the cell goes into rapid replication, these tumor suppressor genes and there are dozens of different types
of tumor suppressor genes in each one of those tumor suppressor gene families, there can be multiple even hundreds of different like with bronca genes there's dozens and dozens and dozens and dozens of different
bronca genes. The most common and most research tumor suppressor gene is the P53 gene, but you don't hear quite as much about that that's in all different cancers not just
breast cancers, but a tumor suppressor gene will turn on if the cell goes into rapid replication and will help your body kill that cell will stimulate a poptosis of that cell. So if you have defects in tumor suppressor genes and you get cancer for from some other
thing, you know, anything that gets inside the cell and who caused damage to the DNA and damage to the replication cycle, the cell can go into rapid replication, that is that's what cancer is.
Then it's that's what the cause is, not the tumor suppressor gene defect, and if I have defects in my tumor suppressor gene and something else caused damage to the replication cycle the
cell and my cell is going to rapid replication, then I will have a harder time stimulated response to kill that cell. That's the whole idea about tumor suppressor genes, tumor suppressor genes defects and tumor suppressor genes do not cause cancer. So they're not the cause of cancer. Now there are a few types of cancer that have genetic origins, they're very rare. So 99% of the people that develop
cancer, it really has no genetic cause. Now if you have defects in tumor suppressor genes, it can be harder to know that to signal to the body that there's a cancer growing so that can give cancer a better ease of development and a smoother
high way to grow and to travel on, but it is not a cause. Hopefully that helps. I do have a video on tumor suppressor genes and good genes in the region's course. So look at that video too.
Next question, do defects in histamine genes cause allergies?
The answer is no. So first we have to define the word allergies. So there's allergies to which are hypersensitivities to airborne environmental type things. So if I have a pollen allergy, it's a hypersensitivity to pollen.
I do defects in histamine genes cause that, no, but they are a big factor in that. So if I have defects on my HNMT genes, let's use as an example, I don't clear, I don't make histamine very well in the tissues, or histamine DAO enzyme to break down histamine in the tissues. So I don't break down histamine in laboratory markers in the tissues very well.
So when I am exposed to some airborne allergy or something like that, and I have a reaction, I don't get rid of it very quickly.
I can develop antibodies to certain things, even like an airborne allergen, and that's what you deal with with food allergies. It's because you develop antibodies to that peptide of that food.
And if I have a bunch of defects on all my histamine genes, I will most likely have greater symptoms when I eat that food. But even if I have no defects, let's pretend I have this perfect histamine genes, and I have antibodies to, let's say, gluten, and I eat gluten. It's still going to affect me.
So it's not the defects in the histamine genes that cause me to be affected by something that I'm exposed to that if I have antibodies to that thing.
So histamine gene defects don't cause allergies, but when you have defects in your histamine genes, they can make allergies that you have way worse, because you don't clear histamine very well.
Next question. How long does it take to heal your genes? Well, tell you, we get this question just about every time, and we have to understand we don't heal our genes. We are just supported issues that we have with our genes. So when I have defects in my genes, it doesn't mean that I'm going to have problems. It just means that
epigenetically, when I'm exposed to other things in my environment, and I have defects in that gene, it gives me a greater propensity to have an issue with that function of that gene.
I'm not going to heal my genes. I know there's practitioners out there that say, oh, we could heal your genetic defects. Well, there's no evidence of that. Show me the evidence. It should be really easy to prove.
Here's this person's genetic profile. We did a genetic profile. They have H-N-M-T-G defects. Let's use that as an example again. And then we did this X-Y-Z protocol, and then we did another genetic profile, and they don't have those defects. That's why I never recommend people run their genes again.
Unless I've had people run their genes again if they're exposed to a really bad poison, and they survived, we run their genes again, and they actually have more defects, but you're not going to have healing of the defects.
You could cause more defects if you're exposed to more toxins or poisons. The idea is not to heal your genes. Why are we running genetics then? Because we want to support those pathways that have issues.
So that we know that symptoms that we currently have, it's not because we're crazy. We have genetic issues there. We need to support it and to be preventative.
We run our genes to go, hey, here's my genetic profile. I want to, that means I'm going to get serious about X-Y or Z, because I have issues there and I couldn't end up surfacied as a major problem in my life.
So I'm going to protect myself. So that's why you look at your genetics to make those changes in your life so that you don't have the epigenetic factors that make a person worse with the defects that they do have.
Okay, thanks so much. I hope this helped all of you, and we'll see you next time. Bye-bye.